Prof: Okay,
everybody has the handout?
Let's begin organizing the
day's work.
I will begin by taking the
snapshot you have in front you
and than using the data
animation on the board to give
you a sense of the dynamic
process,
which is hidden in the static
diagram before you.
Our real interest is in the
dynamic process and the statics
are just like,
for example,
a quote on the Dow Jones for
2:32 in the afternoon.
It's a moving target and the
motion is what's interesting.
That's the first thing we're
going to do.
The second thing is to look at
the "dismal science"
of economics as conceived by
Thomas Malthus,
whose principle work appeared
in 1798 and 1800,
and which put forward a theory
to the effect that nearly
universal poverty was an
essential and inevitable fact of
human existence.
Thank God he was wrong.
Third, we'll look at Gregory
Clarke's exploration of Malthus'
world.
Clarke is the author of
Farewell To Alms,
which I hope all of you have
begun to find your way through.
It's available at Labyrinth.
Clarke is something of a
curmudgeon, and he offers
interpretations,
which should provoke argument.
For example,
he interprets the demography of
England in the Malthusian
period,
before the great surge in the
economy,
in essentially Darwinian terms,
Darwinian both with respect to
culture,
so social Darwinism,
but also with respect to
biology.
He flirts with the idea that
the children of the wealthy were
genetically superior to other
children being born in early
modern England and that that
fact has something to do with
why the great economic surge
took place first in England;
actually more broadly the
United Kingdom.
Finally, and this is a long
agenda, finally I'm going to
look at economic biology.
In particular,
at what is called the world
demographic transition.
The world demographic
transition takes--
it is as nearly regular as
clockwork and it takes societies
from poverty,
short life spans,
high birthrates,
high death rates to relative
affluence combined with capital,
relative affluence with long
lives,
low birthrates,
low death rates and lurking
behind the diagram before you is
the confluence of the great
economic surge and the world
demographic transition.
So forty-five minutes from now
we should be at that point.
The diagram on the board is the
work of Swedish economist Hans
Rosling,
and it is a data animation,
it's set up as follows:
income per capita is on the
horizontal dimension,
and that income per capita is
scaled logarithmically.
I'll switch that out in a
minute but we'll start with the
logarithmic scale and on the
vertical dimension is a linear
scale for life expectancy at
birth.
The bubbles represent
countries, the larger the bubble
the greater the population of
the country,
the bubbles are color coded to
the map upper right,
so all of the western
hemisphere is shown in yellow;
Europe and North Asia in orange
and so forth,
and notably Sub-Saharan Africa
in blue.
You'll also find special
interest in the green bubbles
representing the states of the
Middle East.
Now let's just play this,
it is a time series,
it's 200 years of time series.
The bubbles start here in the
year 1806 and begin moving.
Yes, you're going to need a
microphone, let's hand it to
you.
Student:  Do the
diagonal lines indicate
>.
Professor Douglas W.
Rae:  Say again.
Student:  Sorry,
do the diagonal lines--
Prof: Yeah they cast
doubt on the data.
While you're on stage here what
did you just say?
Student:  We just
watched 200 years of development
for a whole series of countries.
What I thought some of the more
interesting ones were the
countries that either--
they just showed a clear trend
the entire time but there were a
few yellow balls sort of start
overtaking all the other
countries around them as you're
passing them,
and also there were a few that
sort of went up and down,
and it went to the exact same
income per person for a long
period of time.
Prof: Some of them seem
stuck.
And was it mainly yellow balls
or were there some orange balls
out there?
Student:  No,
no in fact the ones going up
and down the most and then one
comes first--
Professor Douglas W.
Rae:  No,
no in the ones that were in the
lead.
Student:  Oh,
it was a bunch of orange,
there were just a couple
yellow, and it was generally
orange.
Prof: Okay.
Now hand the microphone to
somebody else,
we're just going to pass it
around here and get people
talking.
No, no don't hand it on.
If you were going to describe
to someone who wasn't here what
the main pattern was taking into
account the two variables,
what would it be?
Student:  Generally
movement toward the upper right
hand corner.
Prof: Okay lower left,
upper right and lower left,
upper right and since they're
not here they don't know what
that means.
Student:  Toward greater
income per person as well as
greater life expectancy at
birth.
Prof: Okay,
so there is something by and
large good happening in the
data.
Now there are--let's pass it
onto Yale Egyptology here.
Does the--is the progress with
respect to biology and wealth
evenly distributed or not so
evenly distributed?
Student:  No,
it's not evenly distributed
because they all--
all the balls start down in the
lower left hand corner at the
beginning very tightly packed,
while they all eventually move
up and over to the right.
Some are still quite far to the
left and some are all the way to
the right.
Prof: Would he actually
go backward?
Student:  Some might.
Prof: Okay it's hard to
ask you to remember all that
with a rather complex basketball
game on the screen there.
Could we hand it on?
Would you--if you were a god,
or God's accountant,
and you were a God friendly to
humankind,
would you say,
by and large,
what you're seeing there looks
like the world getting better?
Student:  I would say so
because there was a general
improvement,
but at the same time,
you see some of the other
countries,
we'll say the purple ones,
which are located in Africa--
Prof: I think they're
blue.
Yes--
Student:
>
but compared to the other
countries even though overall
adjusted shift toward the upper
right hand corner,
but it wasn't evenly
distributed.
Prof: Okay, terrific.
Pass the mic straight back,
please.
Do the dots,
or the bubbles,
show all the inequality
involved with all the people in
the world or do they mask
something?
Let's take, for example,
the enormous--look at the very
large light blue bubble center
stage.
It represents India.
As far as we can tell from this
graph, everybody has the same
income and probably works for
Wipro in Bangalore.
In actual fact--I don't know do
you know anything about India?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay, good.
Now we could infer from that
that the vertical side,
the vertical dimension of the
world economy can be thought of
in two phases.
One is the difference between
countries measured here by mean
GDP per capita,
and the differences within
countries,
which would be represented by
an income curve or a wealth
curve within each of the
countries.
It turns out that there's quite
a lot of inequality inside the
bubbles and that that inequality
is most pronounced in the
countries which are in the early
stages of getting rich.
The general pattern,
India is a good example,
and the fiction work assigned
for the course,
White Tiger,
is about that vertical
dimension and how exhilarating
it is on the one hand,
and the crushing disadvantage
it imposes on people who aren't
part of the capitalist
development story.
Okay, now I want to change the
diagram to get a little more
finesse here,
and now I have made the income
curve linear.
So it no longer exaggerates
movement at the low end of the
scale,
and what I'd like you to do is
watch this process and tell me
what you think you're seeing.
These are the same data just
projected differently.
Now watch for some shooters.
Now let me do the last half of
that projection once more and
then we'll try to talk about it.
Could we get a mic up and going
in that section please?
We're going to play from--let's
go around 1900 here.
Okay, so over here,
who's got the mic?
Can you describe the path that
the vast majority of the
countries followed?
Student:  The majority
of the countries within the
graph gain
>
Prof: Okay,
so what's just been said is
that the majority of the
countries show modest gains in
income per capita and
substantial gains in longevity,
so they move vertically,
more or less vertically,
and then they pass second base,
so to speak,
and turn right across the
income field.
Let's run it once more.
Pass the mic please;
I'm going to ask the next
person to take a shot at which
countries are the shooters,
which defy what I just said.
Who's got the mic?
Who do you think those shooters
are?
Student:  The shooters
seem to be Europe,
and the Middle East,
and North Africa.
Prof: Is there--what are
the--how would you go about
getting huge gains in income per
capita without going through the
prior step of having people live
quite awhile?
How would you get--what might
make that feasible?
Student:  Especially for
the green countries it seems
that GDP per capita really
spiked in a few decades.
Prof: Okay what--don't
hold us in suspense,
the green countries might have
a lot of?
Student:  Oil.
Prof: Oil,
okay so the oil states,
if you bracket the oil states
you've got a very general
worldwide pattern of modest
gains in income combined with
substantial gains in public
health,
followed by continued gains in
public health,
though at a decreasing rate
combined with large gains in
income per capita.
Now notice that the point made
five minutes ago still holds.
When I say that the GDP per
capita of a country doubled in a
period, does it mean that the
GDP of most people in that
country doubled?
The answer to that--can we get
the mic to center--I'm sorry
where's the mic here?
There we go--yep go ahead.
Student:  Not
necessarily, because the chart
doesn't take into account income
and inequality within the
country itself.
Prof: Okay,
and let's think of the oil
states for a minute.
What generally happens to the
vast share of--
large shares of revenue from
oil extraction in the middle
decades of the twentieth
century,
which is what we're talking
about?
Student:  It remains
concentrated in the hands of a
few, like, politically connected
individuals probably ruling the
country.
Prof: Okay,
they either remain in the hands
of a local elite,
for the most part,
or they are siphoned off by a
large international energy
company,
but the vast majority of people
in such a society often don't
benefit very much from that,
and that becomes a huge issue
in world politics and in
attitudes toward capitalism.
Okay the URL of this data,
and I've explored here less
than 1% of its potential,
is www.gapminder.org.com and it
is a resource I would like you
to use in the background for
this course.
Just out of curiosity how many
of you had used it before?
Okay the rest of you should
join in.
This is the most useful
technique for staying awake
while thinking about numbers
late at night that I have ever
seen.
I showed it to grandchildren
ranging down to four and they
all love it.
Alright now this is the diagram
that Clarke presents at the
beginning of his book.
It's taken from Angus Maddison,
who is the lead researcher on
everything before 1800 in
economic history these days,
and literally every--there are
perhaps fifty books that touch
on this material and every one
of them is Maddison reformulated
and resliced.
These are the four things I
told you we were going to do,
we've done one of them.
Malthus and Clarke refer to the
left side before the great surge
and the biology part about the
world demographic transition
concerns the movement across
from left to right,
which stands behind these
changes.
Now Malthus and the logic of
perpetual poverty;
Thomas Malthus was a Cambridge
wrangler, meaning he was at the
very top of the student body at
Cambridge.
He was a fellow of Jesus
College, he was a devout
Christian, and he was a follower
of David Ricardo and David Hume.
He was an empiricist.
He looked at the world around
him and devised a simple model,
and Clarke makes it a good bit
more complicated than Malthus
does.
The reason for that is that
Clarke wants to make it look
like contemporary economics,
and the actual equilibrium
story is very different from the
equilibrium story in
Microeconomics 101.
The influence of David Ricardo,
there were three great
classical economists Adam Smith
who we're going to study on
Wednesday,
David Ricardo whom we're not
going to study,
and Karl Marx who we're going
to study in a week.
The contribution of Ricardo to
Malthus was that Ricardo had
devised what he called "the
iron law of real wages."
The gist of that was that no
matter what the technology,
no matter what the
demographics,
the inflation adjusted wages
paid to unskilled labor would
always tend toward the bottom of
the scale we've been looking at,
would always tend toward the
level of mere survival,
or subsistence as they say.
In the back of Malthus'
thinking is both Ricardo's iron
law and the empirics of 200
years of stagnate wages,
which the English working class
had experienced.
Ricardo's main intuition had to
do with two forms of arithmetic
progression.
On the left,
counting by hundreds,
from 100 to 1,000 in the
production of goods.
In the center counting by
doubling at each cycle,
the population of the same
society,
and on the right hand side,
product per capita derived
obviously enough by dividing the
one by the other.
Let's say the subsistence point
is half a bucket per person.
You then--this was Malthus' big
point--
that everything progresses
until you get to the point where
people begin to fall below
subsistence level and with a
very unequal distribution of
income,
which was inevitable in this
period,
as it is inevitable in the
present period,
or nearly so.
You would find a solution--well
what would be the solutions?
There are two main kinds of
solutions, one let's generate a
lot more production.
Let's get the scale of
production to not be a linear
flat line but get it do this.
Get production to go north in
the same way population does and
Malthus asserted that that
couldn't be done.
Now we'll see,
and we know in our own
experience, that he was
mistaken.
Production has done exactly
that through the introduction of
capital intensive production.
The pessimism in this scenario
can be linked to a correct
intuition about England or any
other agricultural society in
the period from let's say 1200
to 1800,
that's the period Clarke
chooses.
The first thing that is--that
strikes you about this is
they're not making land anymore.
Only the Dutch make new land.
So you're going to deal with a
fixed total of arable land.
You have, and let's assume,
that you have a growing
population.
The land mass is static,
the population is growing,
let's just assume that for the
moment, and assume it's growing
in a Malthusian way.
Let's imagine this is actually
a photograph of berry pickers in
Poland in the year 1909,
all the visual images here--or
virtually all the visual images
here comes from Wikipedia
Common,
and since we're being filmed
that's important so that we
don't violate anyone's
copyright,
because everything on Wikipedia
Common is public domain.
We get--that 70 is a little
hard to isn't it?
We get land acre,
we've got 100 units of land for
this berry farm and production
increases as we increase the
number of workers from one to
12,
it starts at 50 with one worker
and ends up at 174 bushels or
buckets with 12.
Since the land is fixed the
marginal impact of each new
worker is a little less than the
marginal impact of the worker
before.
The blue series boils it down
to bushels per worker,
and we have cut 50 bushels to
15 bushels, by going from one
worker to 12 workers.
This is all just made up stuff,
but it captures the intuition
about diminishing returns to
intensification of labor.
The constants in this story are
land and capital.
We're not adding new land,
we're not adding new capital.
We're just adding new workers
to an existing quantity of land.
The intuition that guided
Malthus was that as you
intensified labor you got
diminishing total returns,
the red arc,
which implied,
by perfectly simple logic,
a diminishing rate of
production for each worker.
That intuition is really,
that along with the iron law of
wages, is at the middle of
Malthus' thinking.
On the cultural--who here went
to a high school where you
learned Latin?
Ready for this one?
Have we got a mic,
where's the microphone for him?
Student:  If one doesn't
lose, another doesn't acquire.
Prof: Okay,
if none loses no other
acquires.
Student:  No one loses,
and no one gains.
Prof: Yeah.
This was St.
Thomas, and St.
Thomas was expressing the core
conviction of classical Greece,
though not Rome,
classical Greece and
Christianity in the middle Ages
and early modern times.
All the scruples,
all the rules about usury being
not okay, that is lending at
interest being a biblical
violation, all those ideas come
from this;
that the total wealth produced
by and for mankind,
humankind, by and for
humankind, is essentially a
fixed quantity,
so that as I get rich the act
of getting rich imposes relative
poverty on others.
In schematic form we have a two
person society and going away
from the origin means getting
richer,
the budget plane is a 45 degree
angle,
where X Y = a constant sum so
that movements of getting rich,
in either direction along that
budget plane,
imply making others poor.
This was a deeply held
assumption that the best
educated and least educated
alike shared,
and it accounts partly for the
underlying trope in Malthus,
and it tells us something about
the brilliant originality of
Adam Smith and his
contemporaries in the Scottish
enlightenment when they said,
"not so."
If you represent the same thing
with three--my artwork is a
little limited.
You have to imagine that these
are three dimensions like the
two for me,
you and he, and that we've
drawn--that the budget
constraint as a plane here,
and then you have to imagine
that the green dot is on that
plane.
It takes a little imagining,
I've stared at it a while.
The point is this:
that as you move the dot it's
impossible to make any movement
which doesn't disadvantage one
of the three people or more.
The general assumption,
more or less analogous to zero
sumness in game theory--how many
of you have done Ben Polak's
course?
More or less analogous to the
zero sum theory,
or to the way small children
think about sharing Lego's.
If I put more in my contraption
there are fewer for you to use
in your contraption.
That is a fundamental
assumption in this whole way of
looking at the world,
and it corresponds to reality
most of the time.
Most of the time in a low
capital, principally
agricultural economy,
the world acts like this;
new gold doesn't emerge,
new ways of producing at much
higher rates are invisible,
and when we get to Marx we'll
see that he puts this rabbit in
the hat by the way he defines
the value,
the exchange value and the use
value of goods,
he puts this zero sum condition
in by the way he measures labor
and uses labor to define the
value of everything,
so that only by imposing
surplus hours of work on the
working class can we get richer.
Horse feathers!
Just not true.
but that's for another day.
Now Clarke's
explorations--who's had an hour
or more with Clarke?
That's a little worrying.
We got a mic here?
Is it on?
Do you like Clarke or not like
him?
Student:  He's very
interesting.
I think he writes very well,
it's convincing,
and very clear.
Prof: He's convincing,
he's clear, he is empirical.
There's some kind of a chart of
table for everything,
and he is opinionated.
It's not the kind of cool
dispassion that let's say Rick
Levin might value in an
economist.
It's a much more heated style
of argument.
I actually think he's sometimes
a little off,
but he's making the argument in
a really interesting way.
One of the things he does is
shown in this chart,
which is taken from I believe
Page 31 in his book,
and this is total population on
the vertical dimension,
income per capita on the
horizontal dimension.
The red dots represent
estimates taken once every ten
years between 1200 and 1600,
and they form an interesting
pattern.
He combines this with something
else so it's hard to define,
but if you decombine it,
it's almost as if there were a
budget plane here,
and you can move up and down
the budget plane but not through
it so that the total--
it's these dots moving away
that could be explained
Malthus-wise or St.
Augustine-wise by assuming that
there is a fixed total,
and you can use it to feed more
people worse,
or fewer people better.
Indeed, if you pull out the
data for the time of the great
plague, population goes down and
per capita income goes up.
Now how exact do you think our
records of incomes in England in
1380 are?
It's a stretch to try and make
this highly quantitative,
but it's probably not far off.
He then--if you then add 1600
to 1800 you get something
different and you begin to get a
surge in population that does
not correspond to a huge loss in
per capita income.
Implicit in that is the idea
that we are breaking through
budget planes.
Not in big ways,
not in elegant ways,
but there is something
happening which takes us further
and further from the central
tenants of the Malthusian model.
This is Clarke on real wages
from 1200 on the left to 1800 on
the right and the spike in the
middle is at least partly
attributable to the influence of
population decline in the
century before it.
I've drawn it so it looks like
a much bigger mountain than it
is,
it's actually a very gentle
swell and you can find a version
of it no doubt more accurate
than mine in Clarke.
The consumption patterns of
ordinary workers in this period
were very modest.
Food and drink accounted for
three quarters of spending and I
think this is pretty good
empirics.
Clothing and bedding 10%,
housing and heating,
light and soap,
not much.
Life was pretty dark,
pretty limited.
The level of discretionary
spending was very slight.
There's a general rule called
Engel's Law,
and this is not the Engel's who
worked with Marx,
this is Ernst Engels,
lived in the 1800s,
that as real incomes go up the
fraction spent on food goes
down,
and while that's not exactly a
blinding insight it nonetheless
has the advantage of being a
true statement.
Within food the proteins,
principally meat,
to a lesser degree fish,
systematically displaced
starches until you get to our
stage of gluttony.
The most interesting piece in
Clarke is his handling of wealth
and reproduction and I will ask
you to read it for yourselves,
but the gist is this,
that the number of surviving
children produced in each
generation was greater among
wealthy families than among poor
ones.
It's pretty easy to think of
reasons that might be true.
For example,
money for heating your house
and feeding the babies.
The point that Clarke makes of
that is more controversial.
Clarke wants to say that a
cascade of children born at the
top of the pyramid,
a cascade of those children
were forced to be downwardly
mobile for a long period of time
populating each level of British
society with adults who had
begun life with the advantages
of being on top.
It's easy to make up a story,
which Clarke does,
to the effect that the
energetic effort you might
expect from those people who had
been pushed down might increase
the intensity of effort and
competition in the economy.
He then makes a series of
gestures towards biological
Darwinism.
To the effect that Britain led
the industrial revolution
because it had a
disproportionate number of very
able people,
and the assumption here is that
the rich were more able than the
poor.
It had a disproportionate
number of very able people in
all the levels of the pyramid.
Now the empirics on that one
are really thin.
There's an awful lot of vapor
in the intellectual process
there.
This is characteristic of
Clarke, he's really interesting
in throwing out thoughts that
should provoke an argument and I
should think you should be able
to generate arguments among
yourselves on that topic.
Now biology gone good;
I'm going to tell this one in
words and then give you the
diagram.
In every society,
in the Malthusian phase,
life is short and babies are
plentiful so that a typical
household might have eight or
ten children,
of whom perhaps three or four
might survive into adulthood,
and having survived into
adulthood many would die at your
age or something like it.
The throughput of human beings
was extremely fast,
that's a way to think of it in
relation to total population.
Then the death rate falls,
and when the death rate falls
the birthrate does not respond
right away.
In fact, it takes several
generations typically for
birthrates to adjust to falling
death rates.
The consequence of that,
there were several,
but the most fundamental for us
is that the population of the
world went north very rapidly.
They're having lots of babies
and people are living long
lives.
Then ultimately the birthrate
does fall and when it falls we
have both the birthrate and the
death rate at low levels.
People live long lives and the
population of their societies
becomes more or less static
again.
It is then possible to go one
step beyond that,
and the one step beyond that is
that the birthrate overtakes the
death rate on the low side,
and the society begins to do
two things at once.
It becomes smaller and to have
a higher and higher fraction of
very old people.
Can anyone name a society that
is in that stage?
Yes.
Student:  Japan.
Prof: Japan.
Fine.
Japan is there,
Russia is pretty much there,
much of Italy is right on the
edge of that,
much of Eastern Europe is
there.
Now the picture;
this is the population surge in
every continent,
I'll post the slides and I'll
post them in a way that you can
read them next time,
I promise.
All the continents turn north
beginning sometime after 1800
and that reflects the fact that
they are in the progress of the
demographic transition.
Now this is a conventional
representation of the transition
in four phases.
In the first phase we have
death and birthrates somewhat
unstable but steadily high.
Then the death rate falls.
The major cause is clean water,
household hygiene,
a little bit higher calorie
diet, and at the later stages
some aspects of modern medicine.
The birthrate doesn't adjust,
and Phase II consists of the
period when the death rate is
falling fast and the birthrate
remains more or less constant at
a high level.
Then Phase III,
the birthrate is now stable at
a relatively low level and the
birthrate is falling to meet the
death rate.
Then in Phase IV you've got
both of them at relatively low
levels.
Now we come back,
at this point,
to the picture we began with.
Much of what you see in this
diagram,
and much of what you saw in the
dynamic animation at the
beginning of the hour,
consists of passage through the
demographic transition.
Most of what you see on the
left third is societies that are
in Stage II or early in Stage
III,
most of the middle is Phase III
where the birthrate is falling
but you're still building
population,
and the prediction is that
we're going to build the world
population from a little under
seven million [correction:
billion]
to about eight and a half
million [correction:
billion]
before you guys are my age,
and mostly Stage IV out on the
right.
Now the pertinent fact that you
need to carry forward from that
last little piece is this:
the world demographic
transition has happened in a
sequential fashion so there are
temporal offsets.
Societies that are in Phase IV,
low birthrate,
low death rate tend to have a
lot of capital and tend to be
short on cheap labor.
Societies that are in Phase II
or Phase III tend to be long on
cheap labor and short on
capital,
and the dynamic of world trade
which is such an important part
of capitalism is a way of
arbitraging between early and
late phases in the world
demographic transition so that
cheap labor maximizes its value
by being combined with capital
from Phase IV societies.
On Wednesday we'll come back to
the eighteenth century with Adam
Smith, who is in my view,
the greatest of all writers on
economy and society.